if this big crunch were to happen the
universe would start to contract in on
itself Galaxy clusters far away would
merge eventually stars and planets in
our own Galactic neighborhood would
Clump together too and this increasing
density would heat up the whole universe
all that Cosmic microwave background
radiation from The Big Bang would get so
heated that it would be hotter than
Stars we're talking 5,000 de C hot the
universe would become a scorching
chaotic
mess as temperatures continued to rise
and more mass got crushed into a teeny
tiny region atoms would start to break
apart the universe would be turning into
the densest black hole
possible